revenir sur les planches pour protester
c'était l'initiative d'une centaine
d'étudiants en majorité issus de l'école
des arts ce matin ces protestataires se
sont réunis afin d'occuper l'opéra de
lyon dans lequel seulement une
cinquantaine d'entre eux ont été
autorisés à s'installer un mouvement
faisant suite à l'occupation du théâtre
de l'odéon investi depuis le 4 mars dans
le but de rouvrir les lieux culturels
on vient avec les avec les
revendications qui sont communes à toute
la france qui ont démarré à l'odéon au
tns et à la colline qui est d'occuper
les lieux de culture pour revendiquer
les droits notamment l'art en premier la
réouverture des lieux des gueules
culture mais aussi des droites plus
larges comme
me faire péter la loi sur en somme à
chômage le pour la prolongation de
l'année blanche et de manière plus
générale à l'armée sur la situation de
tous les précaires et travaille dans le
milieu de la culture et dans d'autres
villes outre les demandes de soutien au
secteur de la culture
ces manifestants demandent aussi une
aide plus générale nombreux d'entre eux
sont venus afin d'exprimer leur colère
devant le peu d'êtres du gouvernement
face à la précarité étudiante et l'enjeu
que ça représente pour nous là tout de
suite c'est évidemment tout ce qui est
en lien avec les intermittents parce que
c'est notre futur aussi mais c'est aussi
la précarité étudiante en général qui en
ce moment et on a quelques
revendications qui sont d'une urgence
absolue sur les deux points donc on se
séparera pas les deux points et le fait
d'avoir des étudiants en art et des
étudiants tout court qui occupent un
lieu culturel
ça nous permet d'amener ses
revendications de là à la coiffe pour
pallier à la précarité de la jeunesse la
majorité écologiste de la mairie
lyonnaise vote aujourd'hui au conseil
municipal l'installation d'un rsa pour
les 18 24 ans
une mesure qui doit entrer en vigueur le
1er juin et qui concerne environ 2000
personnes mais qui exclut pour l'instant
les étudiants